third party
yeah full moose i mean if
i hate to use these words but if it's
not
now when would it ever be yeah
yeah look i i i have to say
i have always been someone who prides
himself on independent thinking
um and thinking for myself um
the logic of polarization
that has so deeply embedded itself in
american politics
and there's a lot of reasons we can talk
about why and how we got here i would
argue gerrymandering was part of the
situation i could argue there's a whole
bunch of reasons where the primary
became the biggest battle not the actual
general election
for causing people to go more left in
left-leaning districts or more right and
right-leaning districts
resulting in this massive polarization
but that process has created
a totally empty middle ground and around
the centrist logic
which i think makes it really ripe for a
centrist slightly progressive leaning
long-term focused working in the
national
interest political party um
and i think there's a lot of appetite
for it
i think there'd be a lot of people
interested in in in supporting that
and i think you could get a whole new
revitalization of the talent that would
come into politics
right there are so many people i know so
many people i've talked to
really capable accomplished individuals
who we would want as americans
to be serving in office and they would
never consider it
given the dynamics of today they say
well if i ran as a democrat i have to go
party line everything or i'm going to be
outcast by them or if i ran as a
republican i'd have to be party like i
can't do that
and so there's no middle place for me to
think for myself
and i think there should be a party that
allows the conscience of the individual
to come into play
no crazy i mean politically speaking
i mean i i think the two most powerful
people in america
are joe manchin and steve king
i mean the independent and the moderate
democrat i mean it's it's amazing that
one person can say one thing in an
interview
and move the stock market yeah and yet
that's what we that that that's what
this has come down to yeah
by the way you can also imagine all
sorts of interesting coalitions where
you could
pull out the centrist instinct among
existing
existing individuals there that would
jump from existing parties over
and you'd get a huge support base formed
around the country of reasonable people
that just want to put this behind them
kind of dynamic so
i i think that's i think there's a real
possibility of a third party emerging
and have real success
in the next five years yay hopefully
they'll be calling you and not me
because there's that mindset um yep
there you go
so every once in a while if i need
amusement i will
unmute my bubble vision so that i can
hear the latest commercial real estate
person say that
urbanization's going to come back and
come back strong and come back quick
i mean if you think about zero interest
rate
policy and this isn't even just a united
states phenomena it's global
i mean what do you do in a zero interest
rate environment you build you build up
so we have these massive multi-family
high-rises we have more
offices we have more luxury hotels yeah
and yet you know again i turn off the
mute on bubble vision to hear them say
it's all going to come back and stronger
you would dispute that
i would you know so my view on this here
is that
covid was an accelerant uh
this was fuel on existing fires so to
say and
what i mean by that is we had pardoned
the medical pun
many pre-existing conditions and one of
the pre-existing conditions we had
was a greater utilization of existing
uh existing capacities right so
it was okay you have a home but
you know what you maybe are traveling
and so why not monetize the empty home
rather than let people go to a hotel and
so we got airbnb
uh sharing economy or you know what you
got this office space but
you know what danielle you travel all
the time hey you know what i'm coming to
dallas for a day i need an office
you might not even use your office fine
vikrant pay me 50 bucks leave it on the
counter be good to go i'll pay the
cleaning paper fine great so you get
co-working
or you know hey we got all these cars
out there and you get uber or
lyft or what have you and so what i
think you've seen is that co-working
specifically was getting a real tailwind
and now the work from home phenomenon
is taking that a pre-existing condition
and accelerating it
and so you know i've talked to many
fortune 500
uh ceos and their boards one really
large company
has 30 million square feet of space
around the world
has said they're going to reduce their
real estate footprint by 25
in the next five years this is a fortune
500 company this is a multi
tens and tens of billions of dollars and
thousands of employees and
across hundreds of countries kind of
thing they're going to reduce their real
estate footprint
by 25 because they found that hey you
can actually work remotely hey we don't
need everyone to go into the
headquarters every day
we can have three days one day of
overlap we can have surge capacity for
the days where we have but we don't need
this much space
and you're right because of the
overbuilding that's the supply side take
the demand side take the demand side
down the supply side's gone up
and what do you got you got a recipe for
some real headwinds
when it comes to real estate
at least in the in the office real
estate specifically i mean there may be
other dynamics that work in other well i
always when i speak of office
urban i always speak of urban
multi-family in the same sentence
because
one was built to support you know to
support the other
you